so my name is Maya I'm a front-end
engineer at Airbnb in San Francisco and
I'm gonna start this talk with a fun
fact because that's kind of the the
traditional way we present at Airbnb so
my fun fact for today is that I actually
broke my nose on Saturday so it's fine I
was playing rugby it was like very
expected but so if you notice these kind
of like bruises under my eyes it's not
just the jetlag it's a bit of the nose
so I'm here to talk to you today about
right-to-left languages and specifically
the infrastructure we've been working on
to support them at Airbnb I hope to
answer a number of questions throughout
this talk first why support
right-to-left languages at all why is it
hard to do so what tools are kind of
already available to us out there and
then finally how we ended up tackling
the problem at Airbnb with like a
special secret bonus deep dive into our
CSS and JavaScript from like
infrastructure the the takeaway is that
I plan to demonstrate the steps it takes
to get this screenshot to turn into this
and I hope that you leave this talk
inspired to build in the same kind of
support into your apps and help make
more connected web one that's available
accessible to everyone in the world so
jumping right in before we built this
whole new infrastructure it was
important to consider who we were
building it for and why it mattered I'm
of course a bit tempted to go back to
the title slide and be just like it's
the right thing to do and walk off this
stage and be done with it but I'll delve
a bit more into the details it's
difficult to pinpoint an exact number of
languages that are written right to left
but a huge number of people speak read
and write these languages Arabic alone
is the fifth most spoken language in the
world with estimates from about 300
million to up to
five million people speaking some
variant of it couple that with languages
like Hebrew or do Persian and more and
you easily add another 250 million
people in the world who would benefit
from a web that readily supported
right-to-left languages
now since Arabic is the most popular of
these languages we actually have the
most data on Arabic internet users and
specifically on the growing digital
generation in the Middle East and North
Africa internet penetration in the
Middle East is actually higher than the
global average of 51% sitting at near
60% some countries like the UAE in Qatar
actually have over 90% of the population
regularly accessing the Internet
and these aren't casual users 40% of
what's been dubbed as the Arab digital
generation is actually on the internet
for at least five hours a day now taking
a step back even if you're not doing
business in the Middle East or investing
there specifically Arab immigrants have
spread out all over the world their
enormous force on the web four to five
percent of all Internet users speak
Arabic which amounts to about 200
million individuals and is actually the
fourth largest language group the number
of English speakers on the web have
grown about 600 percent since 2000 the
number of Arabic speakers have grown
over 7,000 percent this is huge and
what's more at least sixty percent of
these users say they would prefer
content in their own language it's so
much so that there's actually a
statistical preference towards blogging
and other sort of content creation
platforms which you can extrapolate is
because they want that native language
content but only one to three percent of
like the world's top 10 million web
sites actually have that Arabic content
and I really think the people in this
room are the ones who can move that
metric in a positive direction but for
most of our apps
it's non-trivial so which fix the
question of course why is this hard if
the problem was just supporting basic
Arabic contact it wouldn't be a
challenge we'd simply align everything
to the right and call it a day but of
course Airbnb like a lot of other
platforms has a ton of user-generated
content
well our curated text is shown in the
users preferred language there's a good
chance that reviews listing titles
descriptions names will be in a
different language which creates a
bi-directional text environment and of
course fun fact even if we could control
the language of our content Arabic
Hebrew and these other arte languages
are actually bi-directional by default
numbers are still read left to right
creating a challenge when presenting
even the simplest of information
bi-directional inputs are even trickier
if you have to be able to handle input
in every language that opens questions
of directionality in the UI do you
justify the input according to the pages
content language do you decide on the
fly based on which character the user
inputs
what about prefixes and suffixes how do
you address text numerical and mixed
content there's a ton of open questions
as to how to create the best user
experience when you add a little bit of
directional styling even things like
floats or padding that's asymmetrical
that too needs to be mirrored in our
tale context and finally iconography and
other images need to be taken into
account if the text is flowing
right-to-left it makes sense that arrows
Chevron's and other images likely need
to be modified to point in that
direction as well and this gets you
really into the weeds like what about
IDs or search icons or check marks or
even universal symbols like for
accessibility there's so many icons and
images that may or may not need to be
flipped we're left with a ton of
questions as we explored the existing
standards what became apparent is that
we'd actually need to allow for some
imagery to stay
in the default direction and then we
need to flip some others so in summary
for a truly comprehensive system to
support right-to-left languages we need
to be able to support not only
right-to-left content but also
bi-directional content in the same page
and sometimes even in the same sentence
we need to figure out how to allow for
users to type in content in their
preferred language we need to allow for
custom styles to be mirrored things like
padding alignment borders things like
that and we need to have the same
allowance for images and iconography and
just in case we need the ability to opt
out of all of these things on a
selective basis so the big question
becomes how do we accomplish all of this
with minimal disruption to our existing
code base and our developer workflow we
can begin by assessing the tools that
are available to us
the main thing at our disposal is this
HTML their attribute it's not a new
feature it's kind of the opposite of a
new feature it was introduced to the
HTML spec in 1999 and was kind of
designed as a like one true thing to
holistically support right-to-left
languages this means that the browser
support is super good every browser
supports it but unfortunately it was
built for a very different web so for
time travel back a bit take a look at a
beautiful brutalist airbnb.com we
actually have enormous success just by
setting the dere attribute on the top
level notably this attribute is designed
to automatically flip in line block
content and tabular information so in
the simplified Airbnb design we see that
everything is right aligned as expected
labels are on the correct side of their
respective inputs and tabular data like
our calendar or even the grid of
experiences flows in the right direction
which is what we want one thing to note
though is that inline information like
our header links
remain in the same order even with the
deer attribute set this is due to the
fact that the content is written in
English and actually if we translated
this it would flow in the opposite
direction another sort of weird point
that's on this page it's you to mix
content looking at the prices on our
listing cards we see that the
bi-directional algorithm has identified
the prices leading the clause and as a
result in a right-to-left page that
means it's on the right side if we
translated this per person it would
actually be okay so you can imagine this
page in Arabic it's pretty good so our
first step in addressing right-to-left
layouts is to set this there attribute
on each of our pages on Airbnb at the
same time we set it it made sense to
make that value available to components
down the tree so that we could do some
customization if necessary enter react
with direction so one of my co-workers
Ian eaves Ahmet conceived of and
implemented this particular library it
follows a basic structure that we've
been using a lot for top-level variables
at Airbnb things like break points or
loading state or even our internal
brands the library ships with two main
exports a direction provider which sets
the direction attribute on kind of a
top-level node and a wood direction
wrapper which consumes that direction is
a prop and sends it down to each of its
child's components so in action the
direction provider is very simple if we
start with like a very basic hello world
react app we'd simply wrap the contents
and set the direction to either RTL or
ltr' or more realistically if we support
27 different languages we'd have some
like high level API that returns the
current one and sets the direction
appropriately in practice if we do
nothing else this just sets the dere
attribute on a top-level root node / app
once it's set however we can leverage
its value down the tree by using the
wood direction wrapper and this becomes
quite powerful
if we wanted to have a very basic step
incrementer component with a chevron
icon that we can click and move our step
or forward if we just put the deer
attribute on top you see it works in the
right way and because we've styled these
elements in an inline block flashing
it'll even put it to the correct side of
our text but it's pointing in the wrong
direction and if we want to solve this
in a reusable way we'd want to create a
direction where icon let's call it icon
chevron next by default it returns the
icon pointing to the right but if we
wrap it in with direction we'll get
access to that directional context and
we can return a left icon in the our
tail context so this of course changes
the game if we reference this
new-and-improved icon and set a
direction provider at the top we can
easily have a separate that works in
every language with no problem
so with these basic tools at our
disposal we wanted to investigate how
many of our components would need to be
wrapped in with direction and customized
according to that value and
unfortunately the answer was quite a lot
the deer attribute only handles
inline-block in tabular layouts and a
lot of our pages were styled in
different ways in fact even the most
basic layout characteristics like the
fact that this bucket box should be on
kind of like the far side of the page
doesn't get fixed by the deer attribute
and we'd have to manually address all of
these little style tweaks and spacings
and things like that if we didn't come
up with a better solution and we really
didn't have the resources to deal with
that so um we started investigating
automated options we found a number of
open source projects including our to
CSS flip RTL CSS CSS Janus web pack RTL
plug-in even like ah I've lost all my
slides and all of these packages came
with one major caveat they're all CSS
packages and we'd been spending the past
two years moving away from style sheets
so none of these were really helpful for
us maybe in 2014 when we'd been relying
on kind of an internal bootstrap like
framework but at this time it wasn't
really relevant I'm gonna go on a bit of
a tangent to explain Airbnb had
traditionally been Ruby on Rails
backbone sass style sheet shop but as we
move to a world of react the style
sheets we had were still associated
largely with routes
whereas our components were more feature
based so they might be shared across
multiple routes and cross multiple pages
we also had a lot of generic class names
that were really hard to track down and
grep for which made it really difficult
to determine what component required
which style sheet and which style sheets
were still in effect this was like a
particularly big one if you can't figure
out if a particular override or style is
still being used that ends up in
descending down an enormous amount of
CSS some of which is an applicable to
the page you're looking at some of it
which isn't even applicable to any page
on Airbnb and this was causing a big
performance issue all of these things
coupled together led to incident after
incident I think I sent out six
individual post mortems related to
mistaken CSS stylesheets so we started
considering other options the question
we asked was how do we style react
components while minimizing side effects
performance impact and implicit
dependencies the answer for us and I
will emphasize that it may not be for
you was to couple Styles with our
components and write our CSS in our
react components the idea of CSS and J's
had been hot around the web for a while
and there were numerous paradigms out
there already we were personally leaning
towards Khan Academy's aphrodite library
for a number of reasons ended up trying
it in our shared component library
I'll delve into the basics of how it
works with Aphrodite the most important
thing is the style sheet somewhere in
your component you want to call
Aphrodite style sheet create method with
your definitions it could be on import
it could be deferred to the first render
but that variable needs to be accessible
by your Dom elements Aphrodite notably
also handles fancy selectors things like
pseudo selectors and match media queries
and that's a feature that's built on a
pluggable selector handler which will be
important to us later
what effort daddy does under the hood is
essentially transpile that style
definition object into something you can
understand
notably it hashes the key of your style
and creates a class name for it and then
does any special selector handling to
generate the actual CSS you reference
these Styles objects on your individual
Dom elements using the CSS method and
this in turn turns into a unique class
name associated with that set of styles
and what aphrodite does is injected
directly into the page as a style tag
this is great for performance reasons
because it's only ever injecting the
styles that are actually being rendered
to the page so if you lazy load
something those Styles won't be there on
first render which is pretty cool we
also enjoyed the parody of these
definitions with react native styles in
particular but since the 'greater open
source community hadn't landed on a CSS
NGS solution and in fact still hasn't
really landed on one true solution we
didn't want to write all of our
thousands of components using aphrodite
only to have to rewrite them again in
six months so one of my co-workers tried
to future-proof
this idea at Airbnb with a package
called react with styles the basic
premise of react with styles is that no
matter what technology you're relying on
you always write your components the
exact same way what actually does the
under the hood legwork of that
of that styling is an interface and most
importantly you can easily swap that
interface out by just changing what you
register we currently have interfaces
implemented for aphrodite JSS react
native and even hilariously an interface
that turns your CSS and jus back to
deterministic last names and style
sheets just in case you change your mind
so to write an actual component this
paradigm you'd start by importing these
two functions and the components are
defined the same exact way they always
have been but instead of exporting the
vanilla component you wrap it in with
styles and styles can be defined in a
very class like manner you can see the
parody with how we were using aphrodite
before showing through in this wrapper
you can also easily reference top-level
theme variables that you've defined like
color constants or units or responsive
sizes which is pretty neat and then
because we've wrapped our component we
actually have those styles accessible to
us as a prop we spread them on to
whatever Dom node is needed using the
CSS method which again you can see the
parody with how aphrodite does class
names this method can take conditional
statements as well which is cool if
you're trying to like do some fancy
stuff based on props
you can even dynamically pass in objects
based on prop values or something
calculated this is actually an added
feature of react with styles and these
objects will get converted to an inline
style tag instead of a class name which
again important for later
coming back to RTL after that lovely
tangent the environment created by react
with styles in aphrodite proved to be
both a unique challenge and a great
benefit to how we implemented automatic
style flipping for right-to-left
contexts even though we had to get a bit
creative with what was available to us
in each of these methods having this
abstraction layer allowed us to iterate
an experiment in kind of an isolated
playground without touching either Afra
our own code base which is pretty cool
so when considering how to flip styles
in this environment we established a
handful of requirements that would
inform our approach first we'd have to
handle all directional styles so things
like margin padding text alignment
floats left right positioning transforms
everything second this sounds really big
we wanted zero changes to how our
developers were writing their components
and we didn't want to have to make any
changes to our existing code base third
both the Aphrodite generated sort of
like stylesheet definitions need to be
handled and those inline style objects
that we were dynamically creating on
render and of course we didn't want to
have a huge performance impact on our
application while doing this process so
a tough number one you gotta love the
number one because you know it's not the
final one we know that a few things that
kind of like inform this attempts so one
style sheet creation happens on import
not on render this means that when we
call that method we don't have any
access to react context or other
variables the CSS method is a singleton
global export it's not passed down
through the props which means it also
doesn't have any access to react context
objects passed into the CSS method are
handled at render time not unimportant
that's important we can however assume
that all of our apps have a top-level
dear attribute set so we do have that
available to us and as we noted before
Aphrodite has a built-in plugin system
to handle fancy selectors and we can
actually create our own selectors
through this process so the game plan
was to leverage Aphrodite's plug-in
system to create descendant selectors
specifically we would wrap our default
styles and our dear equals ltr' context
and our flip styles
equals RTL context so this is kind of
how a basic fancy selector handler would
look you notice we added these two new
keys that we would be looking at and the
most important part of this is that we
would search our generated CSS for
anything that looks like a class named
Aphrodite unfortunately doesn't give us
like a nice object to work with it just
gives us up like a string but we do
regex to find those and then we'd prefix
each and every one of them with an LTR
descendant selector or an RTL depending
on which object we were looking at the
effect of this is if this was passed
into our style sheet creation method
what would transform into is this output
CSS and so this isn't quite enough to
satisfy all of our requirements if this
selector handler was all we did we'd
have to rewrite all of our Styles to
have these underscore RTL and lt our
styles in them so we wanted to monkey
patch the CSS method to do all of this
for us this method takes a list of
styles as arguments it splits them up so
it looks at the Aphrodite styles and
inline style separately the Aphrodite
styles go through the CSS call the
inline styles just get appended to a
style tag and so what we did was create
this helper method that would split
apart these Styles we relied on a really
excellent package called RTL CSS J also
added a lot to in the meantime and that
does all of the flipping identifies
which keys like are appropriate for
which context and so we dumped out this
kind of object output and then we just
passed it into the CSS method with our
custom handler this actually works great
and then for inline Styles is a bit
trickier inline Styles can't have
descendant selectors obviously so we had
to call the same directional style
creation method to like split those
apart and then if there were flippable
styles we actually created a fake class
name for that said you
in in the same way that Aphrodite does
and otherwise we just depended his style
tag just as always now we actually had a
decent amount of success with just this
we didn't have to change any of our
components and we found that our
carousels were navigating in the right
direction our switch component which is
all CSS would roll in the correct way
and so it's pretty good
but a number of things cropped up that
led us back to the drawing board for one
descendant selectors don't allow for
context switching and as I mentioned
earlier in the presentation we have a
lot of user-generated content so you
might be looking at airbnb.com in Arabic
but there might be a review in English
and we need to be able to align that
properly
second the sentence selectors coupled
with non directional styles and
directional styles things like border
and border left trying to override each
other actually led to a lot of very
strange specificity issues that we began
exploring and learning about and then
finally when we upgraded to react 16 in
the fall because we have server-side
rendering in our app we started seeing
that whereas previously a client-side
render we'd just win there were
discrepancies between the RTL context on
server and client that would sometimes
manifest themselves and really bizarre
and like undie Bugaboo lays so we went
back to the drawing board looking back
at our original requirements we made one
small change which is that we would
allow changes to our components as long
as they were easily code moddable so as
long as we could make those changes in a
manufactured way via script we made sure
we wanted to handle directional context
switching that there were no specificity
issues so descendant selectors were
probably out and that specifically there
wasn't a server client mismatch in some
occasions so
our new strategy was to create
contextual create and resolve methods
based on direction this notably was a
bit of a challenge because as mentioned
before these methods did not have access
to context in the beginning how this
would look in our interface whereas
before we would have just one create one
resolve method that would have to handle
on everything we split it up so there's
one for the left to right languages
there's one for the right to left for
create this is super easy for like in a
default context we just call stylesheet
create as normal in the RTL context we
simply flip all the Styles with a
package and pass that in to style sheet
decorate instead inline styles is a
similarly simple solution we would just
flip the Styles so now there's no
specificity issues there's no like
challenges between the two it's pretty
good and the way we made this accessible
to all of our components is before we
were creating the style sheet on import
so again no context so we deferred it to
the first render and then picked the
appropriate create method based on
directional context note we're assuming
that our apps are all wrapped in a
direction provider but again this
doesn't consider dynamically created
inline Styles so we also picked our CSS
method based on the same context and the
difference now is we pass it in as a
prop so the main change to our
components whereas previously they were
written like this we would now pull the
CSS method from our props and call it
instead this is pretty easily code
moddable I was able to write a script
that handled almost all of our cases off
the bat and the effect is pretty
stunning with just a few changes to her
like ecosystem we're about to get 95% of
the way to fully functional perfect
sight in Arabic and so we haven't yet
launched we still have a ways to go in
terms of testing across the entire
platform but we don't expect to run into
too much
the journey has already gotten this
enormous way there and we look forward
to rolling out these languages in the
future and making Airbnb a bit more
accessible to people across the world
and if you'd like to learn more highly
recommend checking out a react wa
direction package or react with Silas
package and Kent Dodds awesome our TLC
ssjspike edge and you can always tweet
at me if you have any questions thank
you
[Applause]